[Music]
you see what we have here is a matter of
humiliation and human kindness my friend
here loves his Reign for all of his
stupid reasons and it would be very nice
and civilized if you gents would
understand that principle says you
choose to be uh
Barney what's the word abstinent too
long
dumbbells
you leave me no other choice
okay I won in coming with you I'm sorry
you weren't invited
or won't you be lonely without me
no there's lots of other boys on the
mission
I'm not in the mood
I'm gonna play a little Hendrix
don't start oh I'm starving
[Music]
I always like this tattoo so does your
brother
[Music]
this was always my favorite seat in the
house well these are in the cheap seats
foreign
need to be more careful make me
[Music]
do not Soldier a favor
first things first
I see you like to play with knives well
I play no more if you're gonna give me
the kill switch and we're gonna end all
this come and get it hero
oh
foreign
[Music]
you weren't invited
bad behavior
hey why are you here I got this
situation when I need your help I need
bad friends
cause I'm the new guy is that sniper
don't worry about it I got a
prescription oh guys remember this face
oh shoot it by accident
terrorists have taken possession of
nuclear missiles on a cargo ship off the
coast
but these babies go off
it'll be world war three
you choose this life over friends
over family
It's Time to Get Loud
let's fly baby
[Music]
the reservation
that's what I'm talking about
[Music]
it's not the biggest one you've got
oh it's way bigger than that
[Music]